chris middleton can just flat out score
every level of the floor
he can score three ball goes for
dorian finney smith aberdeen that much
only shooting 31 percent
from the three-point line right in
75 from the foul line as finney smith
hits again
they got wes matthews for a foul his
first and if the opponent is the
clippers
the good chance that's going to happen
as porzingis
gets the bounce on the three
[Applause]
seven point dallas lead doncic great
pass underneath and hardaway finishes at
the rim
in the paint drawing a double and then
two passes to an easy one
great pass by doncic hung in the air
long enough
to wait for the cutting right and now
giannis on doncic
luca puts it on the floor what a fine i
mean he had that
arm from giannis and the fingerprints of
doncic i mean that pass
here's the addetakumbo miss
first rebound for luca 12 points seven
assists another great pass
basket by finney smith timeout milwaukee
nationally as a championship contender
but
they look awfully good right now they
sure do and i can't take my eyes off
doncic
the footwork there how
the pivot passes between two guys
they've missed 11 of their last 13 shots
doncic again going into the paint
what another great pass benny smith puts
it in 10
assists for dodging in the first half
it's as rusty as the voice jeff going
five months sitting around on the couch
[Applause]
finney smith trains at three gifted
players i think tobias harris
continues to get better but in a guard
dominated league
i just don't think they have enough as
another brilliant feed by doncic to a
cutting poison
left home when he was 13 years old to
start playing pro ball so even though
he'll make his nba
playoff debut next week no stranger to
big postseason games
what a dish by doncic there in the tap
in
by cleba
[Applause]
from a confident standpoint that's a
good look
and it's a make and it's a needed make
big time i think about 30 on the season
middleton lost his footing doncic
and so finny smith got wide open and
hits again so
middleton for milwaukee
doncic fires to finny smith who's been
hot
down the stretch 16 straight by the
i'm mavericks even sure he got fouled
now they called it on bledsoe
side out between the legs to kleebo
soars to the rim stuffs it at his mouth
an incredible play
by luca
he's just showing off now with his left
hand
cleeba with a good hard roll but that is
some
shot
[Applause]
wow 19th assist